- Well, last time I saw you was over Zoom.
It's been a really weird year.
- Very, very weird.
- Yeah.
- Let me tell you what
just happened to me.
So, I just got home and
I went to go start my car
and something crawled in
my engine and built a nest.
- What?
- Like a nest,
look, a nest in my engine.
Look at that.
They said it's squirrels because it was,
I mean, it was, look, I don't know where
they got toilet paper
from, like that was weird--
- I don't know, but a lot of people
have been looking for it. (laughs)
The squirrels got it.
- Like twigs, nuts, I mean--
- Kind of hard to get rid of that?
- Yeah, I had to like vacuum
all the nuts and twigs out,
like that was crazy.
- All the hard work
that squirreled did, you just--
- But look, I hear it's a thing,
'cause like I went online and told people
and the people was like,
"Yeah, that just happened
to me two weeks ago."
And I'm just like, "What?"
- [Kelly] That's not a thing.
I don't feel like that's a thing.
- Everybody's like, "Oh, relax.
"Just vacuum it out.
"Hopefully, your wires wasn't chewed up."
And I was just like,
"Okay, all right, yeah."
Wow, right?